à noite actua esta música demorou 20
anos a ser feita faz quarto álbum
chinese democracy dos guns n'roses
alguém ouviu ninguém é nós vamos
aprender muita coisa com o edson robson
e as empresas podem aprender muito com
os seus erros eu tenho várias e hoje vou
falar um pouco sobre uma das coisas é
que nós devemos viver em modo beta
hoje em dia as coisas acontecem muito
rápido então não tem tempo para ter uma
ideia tem que avançar 19 batem mais
aperfeiçoado no caminho porque ele está
acordado e começa a tentar aperfeiçoar
três semanas depois vai aparecer alguém
que já avançou a ideia eu ia começar a
apresentação assim conseguiria vos falar
que uma empresa deve cuidar dos seus faz
coisas que o axl rose não faço isso
contava histórias do meu eu falar que
guardem elas contém um sistema em que o
cuida dos fãs de tal forma que até hoje
todos os conselhos para onde vão estar
cheio vamos falar que viver tem que
saber cuidar de si coisa que o edson
rosso não faz mas outras pessoas fazem e
muitas empresas fazem 82 82 empresas 100
mais valiosas tem mais 50 anos porque
iremos falar que não é por causa de
investir em tecnologia e inovação
mas porque elas são fiéis ao seu
propósito e por exemplo a coca cola que
é se ela o propósito de levar a
felicidade a todas as pessoas então ela
tem um sistema logístico que é maior que
o da fedex e do ps juntos vamos falar
que esse propósito é capaz de se adaptar
aos tempos nós temos nosso tempo são que
metade das mulheres preferem a internet
sexo e que um terço dos homens prefere
internet a sexo e passar esta música
livro é thai e dizer que muitas vezes
para sobreviver é preciso matar natário
a algum serviço que nós já temos a
empresa tem para conseguir sobreviver e
se adaptar o futuro como estas duas
marcas falsificadas rodar a categoria
ter feito o instagram iria ter
aperfeiçoado e adaptação ao digital
basta abrir ter sido a netflix a nova
netflix positivos nos testes de vídeo
enquanto roupas então falaram que vão
acontecer é que as máquinas vão dominar
o mundo e eu vos dizer que sim as
máquinas vão dominar mas a mídia
hoje em dia quando você entrou num site
para ver uns sapatos e de repente então
vamos ao facebook e ela está anúncios a
pata pata pata pata pata participar do
big brother e têm os computadores que os
réus têm um aprendizado inteligente
então à medida que você vai andando e eu
sou eu vou me apresentar novas coisas
sim temos que ter o mesmo mas a boa
notícia que ouvia dizer é que as pessoas
irão dominar estruturas e dizer dos que
é muito vista à concretização da
tecnologia que todas as pessoas têm mais
acesso está mais acessível e resultar em
exemplos como o dérbi que tem mais camas
nos estados unidos que todas as redes do
datas combinadas e os falar mais
profundamente sobre uvas e eu vos falar
das agências
e como as pessoas no futuro já está a
acontecer mas as pessoas podem ser conta
que o ers e serem as próprias pessoas
que fazem as campanhas para para as
marcas e falar também de uma visão
talvez utópica mas eu acredito que vai
acontecer é que os cidadãos poderão
estar a governar o seu próprio país em
tempo real ou seja através de um ep em
todos todos os cidadãos têm podem votar
tem alguma precisava fazer e em tempo
real um dia as pessoas votam
e toma essa decisão realmente que o país
está está está a querer ia terminar como
música assim expressional as cancerosas
e ter assim uma mensagem filosófica em
que ia falar que apesar do mundo digital
está aí
afinal são as pessoas que mais pontuam
iria sair combatida nos ontem depois do
jantar da organização
eu pensei eu ia amanhã vocês lá e não
vou estar a falar a minha mãe sim
então voltei para o hotel e decidiu
fazer uma nova palestra da noite
província de trang então vamos falar
desse processo ocorreu durante a
madrugada e também e dessa forma também
mostrados como aquilo que eu acredite
que é pra minha vida também serve de
exemplo para as empresas e também
mostrar como é que funciona um pouco o
processo criativo
então a primeira coisa que o que temos
que fazer tanto ou ontem à meia noite
como as empresas é difundir a mensagem
mensagem principal no momento os brics
vêm com várias coisas não quer dizer
isto isto e nós não vamos tentar definir
uma mensagem o foco então o que eu
queria dizer o que quer dizer besteira
sucesso tal como empresa com o criativo
são precisas duas coisas a paixão pelo
que faz e é preciso coragem
então é isso que eu queria dizer assim
coragem motivo pra enfrentar um novo eu
precisava de um nome da palestra na
época esta frase é muito longo
então eu pensei coração e com o leão
talvez um pouco à frente mais um ponto e
rex você é um conceito enxuto rima fica
na cabeça
eu posso fazer
faltou quem visual também qualquer
campanha tem meu que visam uma imagem
sucinta tutu não pensa em uma coisa que
é mais ou menos um coração e assim pois
bem mais simples
imagine que estava aqui na tela
o símbolo da campanha
temos o título temos o que vigiou faltou
com que o então vamos falar do coração
quando as pessoas aqui já estava
apaixonada verdadeiramente apaixonada
pelo banco do brasil
poucos talvez vocês não têm vergonha
realmente apaixonada é bom não é
nós estamos assim ela é a vida é mais
fluida nos planos cheios de energia
assim é um sexo nem acreditavam ser
possível depois dela ela foi viajar a
amor da manhã e nós vamos para o torto
alguém fazer isso e trabalhar
eu não assim como seu eu sou um fim
eu sou uma apaixonada pouco fácil então
assim não importa trabalhar uma coisa
que eu realmente um projeto que tentava
algo assim eu eu acordo cedo roupa de
pintar mas tem uma outra coisa
recentemente a oito meses abrir uma
agência em são paulo e tem outra parte
do outro lado do coração foi assinado em
menção às pessoas e nós temos no no
processo de seleção das pessoas
procuradas pessoas que partilham dos
mesmos valores que nós não é eu e meu
dupla era uma chave principal irá ver o
que é que fazem não ter ego
o meu o nosso ninguém mas é assim
fundamental é ser apaixonado todos fazem
então o processo de seleção
nós damos mais valor aos projetos
pessoais dos criativos do que
propriamente o que já fizeram em outras
agências
isso porque demonstra que as pessoas têm
um momento inquieta se ter uma idéia são
apaixonadas por essa ideia tira uma
bunda da cadeira para fazer em um dos
processos de 1º
nós contratamos pessoal gritava 30 horas
apenas depois eu fazia sozinho num prato
colorido então comia 30 hora 30 horas
mil então senti um pouco sozinha mariel
num prato via ficou lindo
só faltava os símbolos do miguel para
identificar melhor as coisas
mas tem uma outra coisa porque o
contratamos
nós enfrentamos a pior pode fazer
qualquer gosta que a gente contratou por
isso não teve coragem
eu tenho coragem de ter a idéia de ser
apaixonado por acender e eu fui comprar
os pratos e eu não vou falar que
exemplifica como foi o processo mas eu
explico
eu tenho coragem de fazer isso e nós
estamos na indústria do novo indústria
do ovo tem que correr riscos
nós vamos jogar com seguros nós vamos
ter só aplicar a fórmula já existentes
isso não leva a lado nenhum
os últimos trabalhos que tenho tenho
feito e até quando nós conversamos com
clientes nós temos nem estamos à procura
de marcas reconhecidas estamos à procura
de clientes ousados pode ser uma marca
papel higiênico se o cliente quer fazer
algo diferente nós vamos trabalhar com
essa pessoa
os últimos trabalhos que fiz por
esquetes
nós somos propensos a senhora está uma
idéia funciona na teoria e nós não temos
certeza se vai funcionar só teremos
fazendo e eu tenho a coragem de pôr
dinheiro não vamos fazer
deu certo uma outra idéia que para a ibm
que inspiram os que vão criar uma alguma
espécie de ativação para vender o o o
técnico giba itens ou sétima associada à
copa das confederações em 2013
e nós chegamos para a senhora vamos
fazer um ep para uma pessoa só
o treinador da seleção do brasil
louco vamos ter 60 cientistas fazendo é
pra uma pessoa nova e ciep na verdade é
para todas as pessoas porque ela analisa
tudo que as pessoas estão a falar nas
redes sociais e não em tempo real dizem
prova na altura era o felipão em tempo
real desempenho deve começar na equipa
principal durante o jogo quem deve sair
quem deve entrar
então é assim era um treinador auxiliar
foi de 180 milhões de pessoas
uma outra ideia que foi preciso coragem
parte dos clientes nós queremos uma
campanha pra pra visa o campeonato do
mundo e eles queriam fazer uma uma
espécie de um hino em que juntava todas
as pessoas todas as nações de todos os
continentes para celebrar a copa do
mundo nós temos eu sei quantas vezes nós
já vimos isso vascaíno mesmo clichê para
além do que eu não sei como é que as
pessoas levam na nigéria
então essa idéia nós vamos pegar no bar
do jeito que vocês têm
vamos dividir por 32 cartões visa e
vamos dar aos 32 realizadores dos 32
países classificados vamos usar um
briefing e deixarmos que els nos mostra
como é que os levam o cliente falar mas
é isso aí não tem dinheiro quase nenhum
pra preso só a pé
e aí vem outra parte eu quero contar
parece ter coragem não é aquela coisa
vou à maluca 1 lançado pra um lado
quanto tem muitas variáveis que nós não
controlamos nós temos que dar muita
atenção a todas as variáveis que nós
controlamos por exemplo dos cats
nós tivemos que achar a pessoa certa
quer o fbi a esquete shorts nós temos
muito cuidado em chegar até eu achava o
realizador nós temos uma a uma
uma lista dos realizadores que nós somos
uns consagrados que tem recebido prêmios
mas tinha um jovem torcedor 24 anos
eu tinha três filmes mas os três filmes
deu tenham cuidado uma poesia visual que
era aquilo que nós procurávamos nós
fomos com ele com visa nós fomos espaço
cliente
as pessoas têm vários realizadores no
mundo que não querem dinheiro assim como
nós não estamos à procura de uma
oportunidade e é isso que nós vamos dar
nós vamos dar isso algum dinheiro para
trabalhar mas acima de tudo nós vamos
falar com ela vamos assim aí vocês vão
representar o nosso país está um
campeonato do mundo de videoclips e além
disso a visa vai promover o vosso vídeo
em todo o mundo os resultados que
tivemos vídeos que assim a nova produção
foram uns a cinco vezes mais o valor nos
restaram as colocaram no bolso deus
porque é isso que os crimes que uma
oportunidade e é aquela paixão pelo para
mostrar o seu próprio país
então é isso que eu queria dizer hoje
muito obrigado aqui deixados com que se
pensava
a palestra muito obrigado